pura bella no I do a lot of stuff
gallstone go I climb trees I can some
assault I can dance this wreck down
Uganda's youngest female rapper is 14
and goes by the name of MC loi she's
become a star in her country regularly
wrapping the news on Uganda's and TV the
weekly voice recording in a production
company is followed by a TV studio
session this modern news format is
designed to reach young people who don't
normally watch the news despite phones
under the bill might have the economy
and sent back to bako farmers back to
Parvati making them to get to know
what's happening in the country abroad
and so on that really helps that helps
them like to know what's going on in the
world cause if you live in the world and
you know nothing about what's happening
then you may find yourself in a bad
thing or problema songs that often
happens to people in her generation half
the population is under 15 Facebook and
whatsapp predominate here young people
would rather listen to music then to the
news so what better way is there to
reach them than to bring the message
across with music Zoe kablooey that's
her real name buys newspapers as often
as she can what bothers her is that not
everyone can go to school in Uganda
that's part of child abuse won't taking
a child that's cool I wouldn't blame
like parents who don't have money to
take children at school but I would only
blame the government which like doesn't
use that infrastructure for like for the
kids at home schools yeah her desire to
remove fear and instill courage
motivates her to teach kids at Sunday
school
37 you will hold a son in your arm work
well he has no son and husband his old
education for all no more corruption she
has even put her demands to the
president wrapping them of course yes
I'm proud to be a ugandan living in the
beautiful motherland a pal of Africa
that grows everyday yannick with mega
malls roads hospitals education system
and so much more but we need some more
and I want to be the first no president
of my country Uganda the pearl of Africa
what yeah the closet oh yeah you know I
met you know that I want to be so he
should just get prepared for MC Lloyd
movin his seat someday according to the
constitution she has to wait until she's
35 to run for president leaving her
plenty of time to get the word out to
all her fans